hey youtubers it's Charlie so in honor
of the big red Viper versus the Mountain
fight on tonight's episode I wanted to
do my breakdown of my top 10 fighters
alive or dead in Song of Ice and Fire
so I did pull a few out of the books but
they're non spoilery and I'm going to do
a breakdown of each one also
congratulations to Sir Jorah Mormont
you're the winner of last week's
giveaway because there wasn't an episode
I just did my giveaway in my bonus video
about the season 5 characters so I will
be doing a new round of the giveaway in
my episode 8 video tonight so that'll
start whenever that video posts remember
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on the
video don't worry I'll remind everyone
whenever I post so Oberyn Martell is
fighting the mountain tonight there's
been a ton of funny fake boxing posters
I'm not going to talk about that in this
video just avoid spoilers so if you have
read the books and you want to talk
about it just be sure to use the spoiler
tag and hit enter like six times before
writing your comment seriously though
their fight is going to be awesome so
make sure you watch the episode tonight
but let's just jump in the ring and try
to find out who the best fighter is in
Westeros so here we go number 10 a young
Ned Stark I'm mostly talking about him
during Robert's rebellion he wasn't big
on tourney's or jousting just
traditional warfare and swordplay in
battle he primarily used his two-handed
Valyrian greatsword ice I thought that
he really deserved a spot on this list
for fighting and killing Sir Arthur
Dayne the sword of the morning during
Robert's rebellion Dayne was a member of
King Aerys Kingsguard and Ned led the
charge during the sack of King's Landing
it was actually right after that that he
found Jaime Lannister killing King Aerys
so he was like the first person on the
scene
killing Arthur Dayne was just a really
big deal because Dayne was supposed to
be one of the best fighters in Westeros
at the time he just like Ned Stark had a
two-handed great sword but his was
called dawn it wasn't Valyrian steel but
supposedly it was forged from a fallen
star and was supposed to be just as
sharp as flurry and steel so try to
picture Arthur Dayne and Ned Stark
clanging these two indestructible giant
swords against each other like two giant
light sabers so there would have been
crazy sparks from the impact hopefully
we'll get to see it at some point I
don't think the show is ever gonna do it
though we know what happened to Ned
Stark's blade it was melted down by
Tywin Lannister into Oathkeeper and
widows
well but after Ned Stark killed Arthur
Dayne he rode back to Starr fault to
give dawn to ashara dayne
the sister of Arthur Dayne that's where
the rumors about ashara dayne being Jon
Snow's mother come from
I don't believe them though number nine
the knight of the Laughing tree this is
actually one of the most mysterious
fighters in the books whenever Jaime
Lannister had his induction ceremony to
the Kingsguard King Aerys threw a
tournament at Harrenhal a teenage halan
reed got bullied by the Squires of house
Hay House Blount
and House Frey Howland Reed just for
reference is the father of Jojen and
Meera Reed they're the ones that have
been helping bran stark up in the north
this all happened way before they were
born but because Reed's are stark
bannermen Lyanna stark rushed up and
beat off the Squires with a sword
so later to defend Palin's honor a
mystery Knight showed up in you know
really patchwork mismatched armor and
defeated the Knights associated with
each of those three Squires the reason
the mystery knight is called the knight
of the Laughing tree was because the
shield had a white weirwood tree with a
laughing red face on it because
defeating all those knights you know
cause this really big stir Robert
Baratheon who was also the attorney in
this super competitive and King Aerys
who's just crazy demanded that they you
know find out who that person was so the
mystery Knight ran off King Aerys sent
Rhaegar Targaryen to find out who it was
but he only came back with the shield
with the laughing face on it the best
theory I've seen as to who that was was
Lyanna stark it just makes sense that
she would be trained to fight Ned Stark
even said that Arya who's becoming a
pretty badass fighter herself resembles
Liana so my theory is is that Rhaegar
found out she was the mystery knight
fell in love they never told King Aerys
about it cut to them running away
together Robert's rebellion etc etc so I
think that a lot of the r plus l equals
j theories flow from the knight of the
Laughing tree and this tournament at
Harrenhal this really epic tournament in
the books so if you want to read more
about it it's in bran
chapter two of Storm of Swords that's
book three number eight Brienne of Tarth
she's not quite as big as the mountain
but she's bigger and faster than most of
the other knights that are still alive
on the show she doesn't have the
experience of someone like areo Hotah or
Barristan Selmy but she was able to beat
the crap out of a weakened
Lannister who is one of the best
fighters in Westeros before he lost his
hand that is I would also cite bran
smashing the hell out of Loras Tyrell
during the War of the five kings but
it's really unclear as to how much his
heart was in that usually the biggest
fighters on the show have the biggest
advantage and they only really get beat
when they make mistakes or when someone
quicker comes along and Brienne is both
big and quick her real weakness though
like most nights is her hubris it's
pretty easy for people to get under her
skin as seen during the purple wedding
whenever Cersei Lannister went all Mean
Girls on her and before they became real
close
Jaime also had a pretty easy time
getting under her skin I would really
like to see a fight between Brienne no
Faris and just because I think they'd be
pretty evenly matched you know Brienne's
much bigger but Obara fights was a
really giant pipe just like her father
Oberyn Martell number seven Jaime
Lannister when he still had two hands
Jaime actually earned his knighthood by
killing the smiling Knight when Arthur
Dayne and a bunch of King Aerys men were
trying to rescue someone from a big
group of Outlaws called the Kingswood
Brotherhood think of them as being like
the previous iteration of the brave
companions or Locke's group on the show
the smiling Knight is kind of like the
previous version of the mountain you
know super big super psychotic super
dangerous
whenever Arthur Dayne found out Jaime
killed that smiling Knight he knighted
him immediately on the battlefield
funny side story after all this happened
Jaime found out that Tywin wanted to
marry him off to Lysa Tully yes that
same Lysa Tully that took a trip through
the moon door
Cersei suggested that he joined the
Kingsguard to escape and be close to her
Cersei is pretty selfish but in this
case I'd say she helped Jaime sidestep a
pretty big landmine just for reference
to when all this was happening Jaime was
about Jon Snow's age but number six
Greatjon umber he's the head of house
number there stark bannermen he was at
the red wedding and was taken captive by
the phrase but he is still alive on the
show right now the reason he's on this
list is because he's one of the only
people Jaime Lannister thinks could beat
him in a fight obviously talking about
pre-accident Jaime Lannister great Jon
is you know huge like the mountain but
he's not psychotic so he's only really
dangerous whenever he's in battle
because he's so huge he willed a
two-handed great
that's even bigger than ned stark's it
isn't Valyrian steel but Robb Stark
called it the ugliest blade he's ever
seen when he said ugly I think he just
meant fearsome-looking number five the
mountain we just met the new actor
playing the mountain in episode seven
it's the third person to play that role
he's supposed to be about eight feet
tall and weigh about 420 pounds that
makes him the largest human person in
the world at least that we know about
for example if strong Bell wasps were on
the show I still think the mountain
would be bigger his armor is crazy
it's so heavy that he's the only one
that can wear it and still move it's the
thickest plate of any armor in Westeros
underneath which he has a layer of chain
maille and then underneath that a layer
of boiled leather he is a really big
dumb animal compared to other more
scholarly characters in the show but he
has excellent warrior instincts so add
excellent fighter to fortress like armor
and you get an almost invincible fighter
supposedly he has really severe
headaches that are either caused by his
gigantism or like a blow to the head
during a tournament there's a theory
that this is part of the reason why he's
so psychotic you just suffered a brain
injury that went untreated I have a
really big theory about the mountain as
it relates to the character Robert
strong but since we haven't met that
character I'm gonna wait till season 5
to talk about that just in case there
are any spoilers so if you want to talk
about Robert strong theories in the
comments please just use the spoiler tag
and hit enter a couple times but moving
on number four Oberyn Martell at the red
Viper yes I totally think Oberyn Martell
is a better fighter than the mountain
please do not go crazy with spoilers in
the comments the reason I think he's
better is because he's way way quicker
in addition he has like an 8 foot long
pipe that he fights with and he has
expert knowledge of poisons remember he
forged a couple maesters change so he's
really really smart all those things
added together just give you the tools
you need for fighting someone like the
mountain will talk a lot more about that
whenever I post my episode review later
tonight number three areo Hotah he's
like the Barristan Selmy of the Martell
family in Dorne he protects oberyn's
brother prince durant and wields a
really long axe that's about six feet
originally he's from the Free Cities and
he was trained by the bearded priests of
Noir
the comments saying about the order is
is that their wedded to their axes
they're like a really prominent fighting
school that trains people to fight and
protect just like Barristan Selmy he's
very proper and formal and utterly loyal
to Prince Duran obviously in bearson
zombies cases Daenerys though
and number two Barristan Selmy he
trained with sir Duncan the tall and
Prince Duncan the small from the dunk
and egg stories he went on to become one
of the greatest nights in the history of
Westeros but early in his life he earned
most of his respect during the war of
the ninepenny kings after he killed one
of the Blackfyre pretenders he was also
at that very famous tournament of
Harrenhal the one with the knight of the
Laughing tree he ended up getting
unhorse by a Rhaegar Targaryen who ended
up winning the tournament but I still
consider Barristan Selmy to be a better
fighter
it's like Ned Stark's said to Jaime
Lannister play fighting in tournaments
is one thing fighting on the battlefield
is a whole other and my number one
fighter in Game of Thrones and A Song of
Ice and Fire a young Robert Baratheon
even though in the show we've only seen
him after his better years are over when
he was young he was at the Hollywood
leading man of Westeros not super bright
but super charismatic and an amazing
fighter if they had holodecks on Game of
Thrones he basically would have just
spent his entire life in a never-ending
battle that's why he peaked during the
rebellion because he was at the height
of his physical prowess and he was just
so good at making war he just enjoyed
that lifestyle but because this list
should have been like a top fifty here
are a bunch of people that I think
deserve to be mentioned but I just
couldn't find spots for strong Bell was
the Hound Syrio Forel Arthur Dayne sir
Duncan the tall
Obara sand and daeron the young dragon
there's a ton of other characters that
we just don't know a lot about so I'm
hoping that the future books just
provide some extra context now it's your
turn though let me know who do you think
is the best fighter in Game of Thrones
either on the show or in the books they
can be alive or dead later this year
there's a book coming out called a world
of Ice and Fire
that will hopefully fill in a lot of
historical gaps because there are a ton
of big events like the tournament of
Harrenhal and all the different wards
that we don't know a lot about I'll be
sure to do a bunch of bonus videos
whenever
comes out in October in related news
Oberyn Martell vs. the mountain tonight
be sure to subscribe to get my video
I'll be sure to post it right after the
episode airs right now you can click
here to watch that all out of the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to learn more about the
new characters coming in season 5 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight high fives
you